welcome back well the last time he was
on the show Dominic rob was pitching to
be Prime Minister
but having failed to reach the final two
he is now back in the favorite in the
race Boris Johnson
Dominic Roth thank you very much for
being with her morning ok so here would
be a better Prime Minister than you are
boys Johnson oh look we look forward not
back
and he's got the support of MPs and I
think that's crucial
so I'm supporting him as you know and
mainly because I think he'll get bricks
it delivered think we need that finality
to get it done come what may by the end
of October he's been very clear about
that but also the other policies he's
been talking about tax cuts for lower
middle income families the increase in
the education budget which is crucial to
social mobility I think he's the the
candidate with the most optimism about a
future and we need a bit of that figured
out of this rut I mean you saying that
the very first thing you said I've got
Boris Johnson was it he'll get bricks
that done he'll deliver it but I was
speaking to some GM early on the show
who said that he's going to try
everything in his power to effectively
block and No Deal happening and there
are many MPs like it he said up to 30 or
at least 30 Conservative MPs he will do
that I mean there's going to be an
almighty parliamentary showdown isn't
there in the autumn if as many think is
the most likely thing to happen the
Boris Johnson Prime Minister tries to
leave without a deal I thought was very
missing Sam rode back from any
suggestion that he would vote with
labour on a vote of no-confidence I was
you know quite important the make your
show like the buy/sell would worry
Stuart Sam keema the more they actually
back away from that and I think that
he's been very clear about no duel I
wasn't trying to use the relation to
stop sure you think that's impossible
don't you know there's two things here
there's a principled argument which is
that we all Sam myself all of the
Conservatives were elected on a
manifesto which said that we would leave
come what may with a deal or with no
deal by the end of Marx that hasn't
happened we're all no deal wasn't
specifically it was absolutely
explicitly in the manifesto and we're
all it's incumbent on all of us as
politicians to keep our promises there's
also then the practical side of things
we've had two attempts recently to take
control of the order paper to deal with
what are called the financial estimates
but basically government spending and
try and use that to choke
the possibilities of leaving at the end
of October and so far they've failed and
I think there has been a dawning since
the European elections that we've got to
get this delivered the thing that is
holding Britain back economically
politically in every way is this rut
worried and we've got to get out of it
and we won't do that until we deliver
brexit at the same time though you know
and I know that there are many MPs
majority of them he's really he won't
accept that they are against new top
ranked said do you think the program
Parliament maybe something that a future
Prime Minister would have to look at to
getting to get that through and I think
it's highly unlikely possible well I
think it's highly unlikely and Boris has
been very clear about that highly
unlikely and an undesirable and but the
run hasn't ruled out as you didn't the
issue about ruling things out is we want
Brussels to have a very clear
understanding of a very clear message
that will leave at the end of October
come what may and that is the way we
give ourselves the best shot of getting
a deal which in Venice I think most of
us want and so if you if you take WTO
brexit if you take walking away off the
table you weaken our chances of getting
a deal that we want so it's a
negotiating tactic them know it's both
the principle of finality that I think
the country needs so we can move on but
also it does give us our in any
negotiation whether it's a business in
the NGO station a diplomatic one or a
big political and like this I think the
other side need to know that you won't
just accept any terms that they dictate
so that effectively means that the
threat Pro Parliament has got to be a
genuine London I just think you say more
generally across the board things won't
be taken off the table I mean some
people would would be really really
alarmed at this that this is effectively
over right writing the Parliament true
sovereignty which is what you know the
referendum was about I don't think so
actually what happened is that we the
politicians and MPs gave to the British
people the decision on this and I don't
think it's right through all the
shenanigans and devices and ruses that
have been conjured up that decision
which has been made by the British
people is somehow stolen back away from
them so actually this is about a higher
duty which is to give effect to the
promises we've made to the people of
this country we heard just before your
interview four-minute batter's yes the
president of the National Farmers Union
who is saying how devastating in urdu
brexit would be for her industry I mean
doesn't that does that worry you she
also
said the boss Johnson by the way I
hadn't even bothered to reply to her
letter well I don't know about the
correspondence issue man the nf use
position has been very clear throughout
look there are certainly some sectors
and we know about the just-in-time
manufacturers we know about farmers
where there are Swiss here but we need
to manage those risks with a can-do
spirit with giving clear indication will
support all of our sensitive industries
through this but let's also not just
talk about the risk this week alone
we've had Amazon announcing 2,000 new
jobs in this country we've had Jaguar
Land Rover saying a new line of cars
going to be built in the Midlands we've
had NTT they also said about the
importance of getting you know a good
break that difference but sure but
they're making this decision come what
may and then we've had NTT a big
Japanese tech firm saying that their 11
billion global business will be
headquartered in the UK I think the one
thing above all people want to see is a
bit of can-do spirit some optimism and
that's why I think Boris Johnson is the
guy that encapsulate that epitomizes
that and is the right person to lead us
at this time talking about can-do spirit
we all know how difficult the
parliamentary arithmetic is when it
comes to brexit do you think that Boris
Johnson might call a sneaky election in
the autumn to try and change the numbers
no I don't think so I think it's
unlikely but I look you know that you
need to ask the team and I think it's
difficult to deal with hide Vettel's but
I think it's unlikely the reality is
leaving the EU is set as the default
mechanism in legislation by the end of
October I think it's much more difficult
than people are suggesting to try and
overturn that that is the will of
Parliament reflected as the default
position what happened in the 29th of
March yeah well sure but the thing that
will have changed is that we'll have and
I believe it will be Boris Johnson a
prime minister that is absolutely clear
that he is going to lead this country
out of the EU the end of October and
he's mentioned this they won't we want a
wide-ranging cabinet he's going to put
together his team and after he wins if
he wins and I feel confident about that
but I think it is important we have some
discipline and cabinet and he's also
talked a bit about that as well so talk
about the discipline cabinet are you
effectively saying that you need more
brexit ears around the table know
something different to that I think you
want a wide-ranging cabinet and I want
to be very careful to protect the
property of any Prime Minister to use
their top team but I do think you need
discipline and you need collective
responsibility
stored and I think that's absolutely
crucial what's everyone signing up to
the idea of a No Deal bright state if
necessary well I think in any team
whether you're Meade your business you
have the discussions about what the
right approach is and then when the
decision is made of course you've got to
stick and play for the team all quit
like you did I guess yeah ultimately in
that case don't sign up to in the first
place I didn't quit because the the
government wasn't doing what I want to
do I I quit because the government was
living up to the promises that everyone
in the cabinet and in Parliament every
conservative stood in the 2017 election
on so I believe that keeping our
promises is crucial and I believe Boris
is the one that will lead us out to the
end of October to make sure we keep that
crucial promise talking about an
election I've came to know your thoughts
on what one of your colleagues Steve
Baker suggested in an interview this
week which was that if there is an early
election the Conservative Party would
have to look to do some kind of deal
with Nigel Faraj and the brexit politic
I don't think we should be looking to do
deals I think the what we should be
looking to do is deliver brexit keep our
promises and then what people talk about
all these deal deal making things and
some people say with a liberal Democrat
some people say with Faraj and all the
rest of it I don't think I don't think
Boris Johnson we've making you deal with
highly unlikely but if you look at the
history of art of our politics I think
the number one thing people expect is
for us to keep our promises if we keep
our promises on brexit I think we're
gonna have a problem with a brexit party
or Nigel Faraj okay I'm keen to talk a
little bit more about Boris Johnson
you've obviously seen how you're backing
him this morning and I wanted to ask you
about something that Boris Johnson said
at a hosta is this week we just have a
quick look at what he said too often
there are parts of our country where
English is not spoken by some people as
their first language that needs to be
changed I mean he's talking about first
language he's not talking about people
who don't speak English at all I mean
you're the son of a refugee yeah yeah I
am and in fact one thing I'd like to see
us do more of this support refugees into
this country learning English I talked a
bit about that during the contest I
think it's crucial in fact you asked me
about my sari and I don't talk to you as
you're talking about your family history
but he's not talking about people
learning English he's talking there
about people speaking English as their
first language
well I think you're Oh
over-interpreting that i think what what
you said so you talked about my father
when he came here the two things that
made a difference he didn't know any
English age six 1938 the two things that
made a difference to his life and his
ability to contribute to this country
was getting his English up to fluent
level and then the educational
opportunities those are two crucial
things opportunity intolerance that we
have in this country and actually I
think it's something it's a two-way
street so I do think we need to do more
to encourage and promote the learning of
English so that actually people can
contribute and of course it's critical
to finding work if you don't speak
English much harder to find work so it's
something which is in the interests of
those that arrived here in whatever
circumstances but it's also interested
in the interests of this country I'm not
talking about people learning English I
think that's quite important and we talk
about that about people speaking English
as their first language they might have
English as a second language they may
have worked really hard to learn English
but they may speak a different language
at home I think I think you're over
interpreting that important detail and
you all the details might not yeah
that's what you say sure so what are you
saying is people at come here don't have
English as a first language if they're
English it isn't up to scratch then that
helps I know what this is like my wife
came here and had to get her English up
to scratch it was good for her it's good
for my father but also it's crucial for
this country we want to be an open
outward looking country we want people
with talent with ability with huge
amount to contribute socially as well as
economically to come here but but
learning English so that you can
contribute so that it is good for the
people coming up it's also good for the
UK as a whole so do you think that he
effectively misspoke he meant to talk
about people learning English instead
he'd talked about people speaking
English as the thought I think you're
over interpreting it but niche you just
looking as well I know I know but I
think most people would understand that
when you're talking about English plenty
of people would come here with English
not as their first language and they may
be conversational but actually they need
to get it up what I think the general
point or is it's making is we want
people to come here with their talent
with their determination we know that
plenty people that come in from around
the world got tremendous work ethic but
in order to fully contribute you didn't
develop sweet the language to a certain
level okay and just a quick I don't know
it's horrible when people bring back
things that you've said when you're
running for the leadership and now
you're backing different kind of it but
I just want to show you something that
you said on the show last time
I do think there is a risk when you go
into marginal seats that the Tory party
gets caricatured as the party of
privilege the party of the elite only
interested in looking after the well-off
are you worried that a Boris Johnson
Prime Minister could effectively play
into that caricature as the
Conservatives being a part of the elite
so no and I think one of the things that
Boris has done during the course of this
leadership contest is not just show that
he's the heineken heineken candidate
that can reach parts of electorate that
others can't but take on ideas so he's
talked about national insurance which is
tax cuts for the very lowest paid at the
beginning he was talking about tax cuts
tax cuts for higher paid and it wasn't
it do you think he's changed basically
no I think he's I think it's only built
up the message that he wants which is
those on low and middle-income thought
to be the first recipients of any tax
cuts you've stolen a couple of ideas
from your competitors well it's the best
form of flattery but I actually I think
in a good healthy contest we battle
ideas around you have a proper debate on
substance but Boris this message
actually being it is very clear we want
to unite the aspirational lower middle
income and working middle class families
in this country and actually saying
you're going to cut the taxes the lowest
pay but also those on middling incomes I
think it's a really powerful message and
just finally I'm keen to ask your
opinion of a story that's in the front
page of The Mail on Sunday today leaked
comments by Britain's ambassador to
Washington who apparently described
Donald Trump as inept insecure and
incompetent is he well I know I didn't
cut past that sort of very personalized
judgment I think the thing with
diplomatic cables and I used to work at
the Foreign Office I'd be quite careful
about what you say which is on a
personal basis in those cables because
it's all very well talking about the
substance of the relationship of
policies but I think some of that may in
retrospect be regarded as unwise but at
the end of the day I'm sure that the two
sides will get beyond any any of those
kind of comments oh you went too far
maybe well no I just think that what
these diplomatic cables are basically
the telegrams that sent back from
embassies around the world to the
Foreign Office I think you need to be a
bit careful about personalised comments
in those kind of misses okay
don't it Rob thank you very much for
coming on the program this week